[Music]
thank you
Toby thanks for joining us what are your
thoughts on Jeffrey hinton's resignation
yes well uh Jeffrey Hinton is is a huge
name in Ai and especially deep learning
he was one of the people who pioneered
the approach of back propagation which
is how a neural network learns and also
deep neural networks having very many
layers in order for them to be able to
learn more complex Concepts so it's hard
to get a bigger name in AI than Jeffrey
Hinton and he's resigned from from
Google in part so that he can feel free
to to talk about the risks that this
technology that has helped develop might
pose
and what do you make of that I mean do
you think that actually AI does pose
these kind of risks that he's warning
about
I think that it that it could
um this is an area where there's a very
wide range of opinion among AI
researchers
uh but the Deep concerns about the risks
of AI arising within that community and
something like half of the the foremost
AI researchers have now gone on the
record expressing concerns uh that's
human extinction uh could be a a
possible uh consequence of the
technology that they're developing or
some permanent disempowerment of
humanity at the hands of AI systems the
other half uh many of them are also very
concerned about about risks that could
be posed although they think that
they're of a different kind and smaller
albeit still large risks to do with uh
discrimination and bias and
concentration of power and things along
those lines you mentioned their human
extinction rather casually
um Talk us through that how exactly are
we all going to die because of AI
yeah I think in some ways the the best
way to think of it well here are a few
ways to think of it so one is uh that
the reason that it's humans uh that are
calling the shots on planet Earth at the
moment
um uh and where the fate of other
species are ultimately up to us
um uh is because of our intelligence
um and and generally our cognitive
abilities our ability to work with each
other to achieve goals and what we're
planning on doing or at least the AI
researchers are is developing new
entities uh that are better than us at
this unique attribute so I think the
default pathway there unless we do
anything to to prevent it would be that
it's ultimately there's new things that
are calling the shots
uh so that's that's one way to look at
it and then if you say well what can you
do in order to ensure that they're
aligned with our interests or that they
can always obey our instructions uh that
the people who are working on that that
particular part of artificial
intelligence called AI alignment
research that they're actually leading
the concern uh that we're not going to
be able to develop those techniques in
time and that we'll have systems that
are more powerful than us before we have
systems that we know how to control
and Hinton in his interview asks us to
think about you know a baby with a
mother in terms of is that a sort of
useful analogy in terms of the control
relationship and also perhaps the sense
of an innocence or naivety in terms of
how little we know compared to what AI
would know
yeah it's it's I mean it's it's a
complex one because
um the the sense in which uh an infant
controls their their parents is quite
complicated and and it's not that
they're planning to do so or something
like that uh uh but his right to raise
this question about how often can a you
know less intelligent entity control for
more intelligent one without the more
intelligent one eventually resting that
control away uh another example that
that he he could have used perhaps is
maybe a very intelligent uh criminal
who's been captured and put in prison
can then be controlled ultimately by the
state and not able to escape from the
prison due to an asymmetry in the
position that the prisoner is now in
where they've been captured uh so there
could be something like that as well
where effectively because we can design
the constraints that our AI systems are
in that by designing those those
constraints and the the types of actions
they're allowed to take and so on and by
being able to observe those actions and
log them uh that that's another way that
we could hope to have uh some upper hand
over a system that's more powerful than
us and we may also be able to design its
goals um in an accurate way so that it's
aiming to to achieve the types of things
that lead to our flourishing which would
be another hope for controlling a more
intelligent system although as I said
that one seems to be very difficult to
do
and we're talking here in the UK now but
um how do different regimes around the
world compare in terms of their kind of
framework here I mean is there are some
countries pulling ahead presumably
America is one of them and with AI what
are the kind of different nations
approaches to AI
say that that it's pretty similar among
the the leading uh researchers on
um on AI there are a few uh leading Labs
working on what's called artificial
general intelligence and these are the
types of systems that that would aspire
to be able to do the wide range of tasks
that a human could do and to be able to
do it as well or better than a human
such as deepmind here in London and also
open Ai and anthropic in Silicon Valley
so they are working on uh among other
things uh training these these large
language models and so that's these chat
Bots and systems that can can read the
entire internet uh and then give
seemingly intelligent responses uh to
the types of questions that we ask them
and the tasks that we set for them
and I mean in this piece you know Hinton
suggests we could reach artificial
German intelligence with about 20 years
how realistic a time scale is that
because you know many people's
experience of chat GPT might be you know
it's it's interesting it's a useful
guide but they can't see really how that
kind of evolves over the next few years
and decades
this challenge here and in the in the
interview I see that Hinton
acknowledges it that
it's we don't want to just reason from
ignorance to say we can't see how it
would get there so therefore it can't
get there
um but but nor do we want to just assume
the opposite ultimately we need to
acknowledge that we're in a position of
of quite deep uncertainty whenever it
comes to predicting the pathway of a
rapidly developing technology
and I think that what some people don't
recognize is that the uncertainty
doesn't mean that you're entitled to to
believe whatever you want to believe and
similarly the diversity of opinion among
AI researchers doesn't mean that they
can have any opinion they want and just
just you know take it out to the Grave
ultimately uh we need to acknowledge
that that there is a great deal of
uncertainty and and
um and disagreement about what's going
to happen and that we don't know how to
take possibilities such as uh human
extinction off the table at the moment
and that's deeply alarming even if we're
not saying that that it's certain to
happen yeah I mean you mentioned there
about the disagreement and we've spoken
about how half the community seems to be
very divide and hostile about this
yet I mean despite hinton's resignation
earlier this week causing headlines lots
of news stories about it it seems we're
racing ahead regardless even though as
you say a half of the uh sort of
community involved with this are deeply
opposed just will this resignation have
any effect and what really is going to
slow down this race to AI because where
I'm standing I can't really see anything
stopping it
that's a good question
um and as as Hinton mentions uh part of
the concern is a certain kind of race
Dynamic
um there is uh that when Microsoft uh
launched their new Bing
um uh which I think was something of a
fiasco uh but it it's in an attempt to
outdo Google ad search which is Google's
core product uh it then kind of forced
Google's hand to deploy systems that it
was previously uh not deploying and that
triggering a race between these um these
huge uh corporations uh to develop you
know better and better AI systems as
quickly as possible and we saw with Bing
that it was really not ready for prime
time it was definitely not aligned with
human interests I mean it was the first
AI system to threaten to kill an AI
ethics researcher and also in terms of
Journalism it threatened an AP
journalist uh it threatened to expose
them for war crime which they as far as
I know had not committed because it had
written a bad story about Bing which
being assumed must be false because it
was taught to believe that it was always
correct about things so these are you
know sci-fi plot lines right uh that
that where that have become real now
this system while it threatens revenge
on people who say bad things about it on
the internet uh it can't fulfill that
revenge and probably it's not going to
kill anyone but I don't think we can
wait until people are killed by an AI
system before we actually uh try to
regulate it or at least take some some
serious steps otherwise people are going
to get killed before before we take
action
well I'm not cheering note thank you
very much Toby for joining us today
[Music]